when you're 18 years old
you do not have the luxury of time
experience space and time
allow you to see seasons seasons allow
you to realize that things end and they
begin again rebirth and renewal no one
cared at least from my outlook again at
that time in that age no one cared that
i was having to smile on red carpets
while i'm cutting my arms up at home in
the bathtub and wanting to kill myself
and just barely not killing myself up
until a point when i did attempt and and
that that made me feel so much more
invisible because now i was being told
you did it you're a success oh my god
you made it and it was like
oh oh wow this actually never
i'm never gonna be okay like i got the
thing that was supposed to make it okay
and it's so not okay and i'm even more
invisible now being seen by everyone
this podcast exists because i love
talking to people and i love going deep
the purpose is to plant seeds of
inspiration we enter a space of
vulnerability and relatability and what
you realize is that we are so much more
alike than we are different to quote
ramdas we're all just walking each other
home and this show is just one step i'm
danica patrick and i'm pretty intense
[Music]
welcome to the pretty intense podcast
today on the show is annalynne mccord
i
have been a fan of annalynne since
she was in the movie fired up
i mean i love that movie it's a
cheerleading movie you may have also
seen her in uh 90210
and she's currently in a show called
powerbook 3 raising kanan
she also has a new podcast called
unzipped
i mean i really
connect with her on
the
healing and spiritual side of things
she's been on a real journey um for for
quite a while i mean really since she
was i'd say 25 um so about a decade of
healing these childhood traumas that she
had and and so
there's a lot of talk about about what
that process has been like for her and
then of course where she's at now in
relationship to where she was and
um she has disassociative personality
disorder is what it's called and it's
really a matter of sort of
splitting or fractioning off parts of
your personality to cope with traumas
and so
um she's just a total open book when it
comes to the experiences sexual trauma i
just honor people that have the strength
and courage and confidence to and and
also the love in their heart to want to
share that
that those parts of them to help other
people and she's just really a light and
uh we we just really connected and we're
totally going to be bffs we've already
begun to be bffs but we're definitely
going to be because um we're on this
hippie journey together for sure
but it was a very very honest vulnerable
conversation about her relationship with
herself and the trauma and the light
that comes when you start to look at
that and and heal it i i had a zen-den
back in the day when i lived in north
carolina uh there was this little pocket
outside of the house but still connected
and it was covered so
i just felt i had like a big custom-made
cushion
and
i put probably 25 pillows on it
and it was just this cute little zenden
i had a little buddha out front and um
it was so sweet
i think zen dens are so important and
just like spaces that feel curated and
feel special and and invoke something um
i wrote a book a couple of years ago and
there's a whole chapter dedicated to
your woman cave
yes your woman cave i love that
yeah but you know the good thing is is
that if you don't live with anyone you
can make the whole damn house your woman
cave
that's what i'm doing
i i actually
so i've
had quite a crazy life a lot of trauma a
lot of stuff that led to me getting into
kind of some crazy stuff sexually and i
had a dungeon up into my in my house
like built a bed like this whole crazy
thing yeah and i finally like it's been
a room that i really don't go in
and i yesterday so i'm stoked to like be
talking with you i'm on a whole high
right now because yesterday we found an
artist because i
we i have people redoing my closets and
all this stuff and we were talking about
the getting this thing out of my house i
have this monstrosity custom custom-made
bed that i
designed
without knowing my trauma like literally
didn't have the memories and all of the
stuff that i got into on
in my life and i'm you know i'm not here
to judge but i everything that i was
into sexually related back to stuff that
i ultimately remembered
in my trauma memories and i talked
really candidly candidly about this
because it's like i'm just don't i just
this topic needs to be spoken about and
it needs to be
a conversation we can have it at a
dinner table and then move on and have
dessert and be fine you know i love that
i love that keep going i think this is
you know for those those brave and
vulnerable and transparent enough
to and strong enough to
say it should yeah it's not everyone's
place not everyone has the ability to
say it but if you do
and then the people that you help are
are ones that would never otherwise get
it you know 100 but also if one of us is
speaking it's all of us
i am the voice of anyone who doesn't
feel like they want to speak i'm your
voice i'm i'm
your voice and you can feel through me
that we are speaking up together because
we're the same i mean it it's that's
that's how i see it anyway but but this
this whole this freaking dungeon bed is
like was just absorbing energy in my
house and you can see like i want a zen
den so i'm literally turning it into a
meditation room but my organizer was so
amazing i kept feeling like just really
not cool about i just wanted to get rid
of it i didn't want someone to buy it
because i didn't want it to be used for
this purpose anymore and she said
there's an artist who wants to repurpose
it and i literally dance i literally
burst into tears i was just like i was
so overwhelmed with relief but also it
was like the universe just saying
no we hear you
we're not gonna let this be something
that could possibly
become more of a you know harmful thing
in any way shape or form yeah a tool in
that regard um
and and
it's gonna be repurposed it's going to
be used in an artistic exhibit and i'm
just like so happy it's going to be out
of my house i already have the design
for the meditation room so it'll be a
this is obviously my meditation living
room there's my meditation bedroom
that'll be my meditation meditation room
you know every as you said in my whole
house it'll be that but but that will be
a dedicated room that the energy will
will go from what it has been to just
being the space that i know i want to
hang out in all the time so i'm really
excited
to go there again and use the room for a
different purpose and having to go
through that that alchemical process of
turning it from one thing into another
and you've talked about that for
yourself and i just think that you know
you said that to change the narrative
around trauma that you have to say like
how did how did we get here how did i
get here so
maybe this is the perfect time to just
start off by like how did you get here
and then we can work in through details
and i'm really i'm you'll find that i'm
very inquisitive and i ask a lot of
questions but you know
how did you how did you get here meaning
what was the impetus to
this transition that you've gone through
where you were able to recognize what
happened and then and then really just
recognize what happened what was that
part
yeah that section so my life is kind of
left out in segments there there was the
um
0 to 15 years old segment where i live
with my family parents home schooled
went from k through 12 in home school so
never actually went to a
typical school
graduated when i was 15 two months later
i moved
or two months after i turned 15 i
graduated and moved out of the house
became fully independent and then you
have like my 15 to 18 year period where
i'm studying acting and i'm in new york
and i'm determined that i'm going to be
an actress and everybody told me it was
never going to happen because you know
trailer park kids don't make it in
hollywood and i was like um has anyone
ever heard of hilary swank
[Music]
but uh i was a little bit of a was as a
strong word i was a little bit of an
arrogant child
i was like y'all are all wrong i'm gonna
prove it and um so then there was that
period of just like just just
really treading through the muck of it
all to make stuff happen in kind of a
forcing kind of way
um toxic hustling i think is what they
call it now
good one
right um i heard that term recently and
i was like yeah we we god we're sold
this american lie not an american dream
it's it's like you you
but literally you go into your life
being told that if you go after your
dreams meaning if you do a career that
we approve of will mean that you are
quote unquote successful
you're going to be happy and we'll be
happy
with society or we meaning your family
i think all of the above right i mean it
depends this is obviously it's
definitely society and culture a lot of
people's families there are the few who
are like be whatever you want free
little bird
i love those people i haven't met them
but i i figured they're out there
but we as society we as a culture we as
parents teachers community peer you know
all of the above
literally drink the kool-aid and then
pour that kool-aid into a little tiny
sippy cup for a child to drink and
from the time where you know we can
start to talk we're we're being asked
what do we want to do when we grow up
and then we're asked what do we do when
we're at an event and it's just so i
wanted to make sure that what i did was
something that i was proud of and
um and that i thought would make me
important and make me more importantly
be seen because i felt invisible i felt
unseen and invisible in the world
because when you're a traumatized kid
you feel like nobody sees you you feel
like you don't exist and your parents
were really young and they had
three kids really fast right so you know
there wasn't i mean i'm sure that you
know as we know well well known and i'm
sure we're going to talk about this a
million different times but you know
child the trauma gets passed on from
generation to generation so something
happened i'm sure in your parents
childhood and their upbringing that
showed them a certain path and then they
did the same thing and so it's about
breaking that ancestral cycle and so um
but you know your parents were how old
were you how old were they when they
they got married quick or they had kids
quick it all went really fast right it
all went very fast
um my father was 19 my mother was 21
when they got married
they eloped
30
33 days after hi nice to meet you
meeting each other
yeah are they narcissists um
one would only imagine um
the
the the whole like
teach your kids not to have sex before
marriage makes horny kids
that's all it does yes sorry he's not
sorry
um but so you know my parents want to
get laid um that's my take on it um nine
months later my older sister was born
two years and two months later i was
born 15 months later my little sister
was born so within a high nice to meet
you
to four years later three kids and some
mid-20s
you know adults if you want to call them
adults in their mid-20s because i
certainly know that i am barely an adult
in my mid-30s i am with you i remember
a hundred years ago i got married and i
was like oh my god like i was 23 and i'm
like oh yeah i'm not even close to the
same person
i mean the 20s are
right the first 18 years of your life
your you're
expanding into an adult you're literally
your bones are growing your your
heights everything's growing
then you are legally termed an adult by
government
agencies right you're 18. so now you're
technically recognized as an adult your
brain that those the neuroscience
community wouldn't recognize you as you
as an adult because the brain doesn't
even finish structurally
structurally developing until 25.
so
so the government's all like you an
adult at 18 and the neuroscience
community is like wow i don't know about
that and then of course our plasticity
i'm a little bit of a nerd just i mean
that's all the time neuroplasticity
neuroplasticities all the time no you go
nerd out on me
i i was thinking to myself i'm i'm
slipping this in but when you were you
were out in arizona and i was like oh
let's get together
because i had heard you talking about i
think it was about your podcast saying
like that your role is like i love all
the shamans and the woo-woo and the
spiritual i was like oh my god let's
have a woo-woo off let's see who's more
let's do it together oh my god i'm
looking my flight back to arizona yeah
and i love i love
quantum physics and i love
um anything that has to do with the mind
and reality so neuroplasticity all of
that and the power of it you just keep
wording it out
okay well i'll admit i was a little i
was two minutes late logging on here
because i had lost track of time
listening to jodo spenza on his uh live
pod he does this live expo with gaia the
streaming network oh that's cool i just
finally signed up for gaia joe's great
i've interviewed him too he's he's
really oh my god you've interviewed him
oh yeah yeah i've interviewed him i've
done a couple i did his week-long
retreat i did a one day in santa barbara
last fall with him
um and like 18 people where do you live
i'm just gonna come move in with you
yeah yeah you should i'm alone i hang
out in your energy field it's the whole
zen area trust me trust me okay okay
we're good we're already best friends
but we're
having a what is i don't know what they
call a girl crush we're having girl
crush right now um
but yeah so so that i'm a nerd i love
joe dispenza i love quantum physics all
these things started to come to me in my
healing journey but that started at age
25 for me and at this point i had this
crazy life moment so the segments of my
life continuing there was the new york
point at 18 i moved to los angeles
as a technical adult
and i you know at this point and i had
lived a lot of life because of all the
things i've been through but when you're
18 years old
you do not have the luxury of time
experience
experience moving through space and time
as joe dispenza would say
space and time allow you to see seasons
seasons allow you to realize that things
end and they begin again rebirth and
renewal for every winter there's a
spring right and this this aspect of
ourselves that we get to experience when
we have life experience is the cyclic
aspect of life
and unfortunately
trauma kids we don't get a childhood so
we are made to either act like adults we
feel like we have to be adults we're
panicked so we're acting like adults out
of just shared reaction to our
circumstances survival mechanisms
kicking in
we feel older than we are
and yet we haven't seen the cyclic
experiences of life where things live
die and repeat right
yeah and the patterns the patterns yeah
so
so that whole experience for me was i
taken this you know the kool-aid that
was put in my sippy cup and i drank all
that [ __ ] and then i like started
filling up my own bottles with it
and i really really thought that whole
arrival theory fallacy
i really thought
in this unthought known where it wasn't
something i consciously thought of but i
had the sense because of everything that
was ingrained in me from society culture
and all the above
that once i became an actress
you couldn't [ __ ] not see me anymore
right one side dot dot and
that's that hit me like a ton of bricks
because
still
no one [ __ ] cared
no one cared at least from my outlook
again at that time in that age no one
cared that i was having to smile on red
carpets while i'm cutting my arms up at
home in the bathtub and wanting to kill
myself and just barely not killing
myself up until a point when i did
attempt and and that that made me feel
so much more invisible because now i was
being told you did it you're a success
oh my god you made it and and it was
like
oh oh wow this actually never
i'm never gonna be okay like
i got the thing that was supposed to
make it okay and it's so not okay and
i'm even more invisible now being seen
by everyone
than i was when i was this kid who just
thought maybe you know
like somebody in the community could
could have seen me and helped well
that's just a perfect example of how
no one can fix you no thing can fix you
no destination no job no
no thing can fix you but you
and so
from to mirror like to show you
people did see you i saw you i mean
shake girl i love fired up okay i heard
i i heard you talking about that you
were the mean girl cheerleader but it
was actually the other way around which
is very interesting but anyway i mean i
saw you many people saw you so it was
happening but if you don't feel it for
yourself if you can't give it to
yourself and so much of that work has to
do with the inner child and seeing the
inner child
that's what i've found in my own work
and my own sort of like big epiphanies
and healing like mom trauma dad trauma
is that it wasn't until i started seeing
myself and taking care of my inner child
and taking care of that original wound
spot right
about like going back in time to that
little girl and what happened that made
her the way she was or him the way he
was and it's like taking care of that
kid it's not some something it's not a
destination
yeah
it's an inside job and it's
you know it's an inside job it's exactly
all an inside job so how how the hell
did you get to the inside like what was
it that helped you realize that um no no
destination was gonna get you there no
job no no tv show no movie nothing
well that leads me to actually answer
your original question which was what
was the impetus of all of this you know
this coming to uh this awareness of even
just yesterday this moment with selling
the bed and not selling it and being
able to give it to someone who's gonna
repurpose it um i got to repurpose my
life
and
in the process of realizing actually
fired up was a catalyst for me to
repurpose my life for the first time
i was being offered 90210 while i was on
fired up
niptuck was the show that i was
technically still filming but we were in
a writer's strike and everything had
frozen in time obviously because we'd
run out of scripts and we couldn't the
writers couldn't write anymore so i had
some off time i was able to do fired up
and
in that but in that writer strike a film
on human trafficking that i was obsessed
with i was so adamant that i was going
to do this film i was so excited i met
with the directors multiple times
[Music]
they were in the middle rewrites and it
got shelved and the money pulled out and
the film didn't happen and i was just
heartbroken and i was on fired up and it
was supposed to be such a fun setting
you know and it was literally just
i didn't go to high school as i
mentioned but it was high school [ __ ]
going on and i just really didn't
understand how i literally went to shake
the the other lead actress's hand and
she like was holding her a little
sidekick and looks up at me like
ew you're the other cheerleader i'm like
um no [ __ ] i'm an actress playing a
cheerleader and also hi i'm analyn shake
my [ __ ] hand um
and it was just this like
the same range yeah i was like you're
going to stream don't look away i'm like
um
nope
not going to let you um it was so weird
and then i got over to my group uh we
were training for a couple weeks of
these you know we had cheer practice for
two weeks before we started filming you
know i did all anyone that doesn't know
fired up is a cheerleading movie it's
the best it's hilarious it's so funny
it's seriously one of my top
top five favorite movies oh my god i'm
so glad you feel that way it actually it
did turn out so funny the guys on there
eric and nick they're so hysterical
dialogue is so good
it's like the best funny dialogue movie
and this was like will glucks the
director write director he was like his
first thing like big big deal thing and
he um he was he was awesome but he you
know went on to do special eye and all
those other things but um but this one
he's he's just he's got that dry wit you
know and
um but yeah the experience was just like
really
really vapid very and what do you expect
right you put a bunch of 20 somethings
together in a makeup hair trailer and
they are you know being they're on a big
sony film and it's the start of their
life and again as the neuroscience
community would say
they haven't fully developed their
brains yet we can't be upset with them
um and and i've actually had
conversations with some of the actresses
who like i'm really sorry that that was
kind of weird back then i'm like
no worries we were child we were
literally kids
but because of the experience
in the moment losing that film or you
know it not happening the one about
human trafficking and this this this
movie that i just was like
surrounded by all this like you know
egotistical
vapid energy
i just was
like what if i
decided to do with my life talk about
your inner child i
reached out to my nine-year-old inner
child it's like you were really off the
mark lady like why did you want to be an
actress this was a stupid idea and she's
like you should have been an
archaeologist like you thought yes i
wanted to be an archaeologist before
that you should have been an
archaeologist dammit um
my nine-year-old self was like you'll
catch up
stupid girl my nine-year-old self is way
wiser than me
um
but so our inner child's always super
wise very simple very clear but usually
very wise extremely wise i defer to her
at all at all times at all costs like
it's just like where are you please help
but so does your inner child have a name
have you given your inner child name
little anna i call her a little little
anna um because i'm anna lynn and so
she's little anna um but yeah so so
that this particular period
put me in the
i'm fast forwarding a lot but
all of it culminated to the point where
i was
in a place where i realized i have my
what i've had my what since i was nine
years old what i wanted to do in the
world i wanted to be an actress this is
what i wanted to do
why
why did i want to do this i didn't know
i didn't know that i felt invisible i
didn't know that i needed to be seen my
little inner child and i like i said we
were more at odds at the time she was
kind of like i don't trust you and i was
kind of like i'm smarter than you um so
it was just you know two inner children
one wasn't an adult one was acting from
an adult body the other was just like
bad girl um
so that point happened
then i
my
very good friend who's my first acting
partner in new york jessica menhas who's
the founder and ceo of i'll go first
which is an incredible platform for
trauma survivors and individuals who
have gone through really horrific things
to come and tell their story and go
first because
she and i realized in the work that we
do
taking shame out of the room was a big
part of what we had to do and and it
required us to go first because shame
just
it's an illusion right it literally it's
like
it's like a dark room you turn on the
light one person turns on the switch and
everybody can see
and so
one person turns on that light and shane
just evaporates like the darkness and in
a room with a light on and so she
created that but she she
had been working fighting human
trafficking for years she was the first
one to educate me on this issue we end
up going to cambodia
i think i'm gonna go save children they
saved my life so now i have this why but
then i was projecting all of my problems
that i still don't know i have onto
these beautiful wonderful little girls
who were way wiser again children um
were way wiser than i could ever imagine
being and they are loving me and
compassionate and i don't know why i'm
being loved i wanted love but now i
don't know how to take it i'm like i'm
so confused so i go through that for
several years are you learning it you
haven't ever done it before so you were
learning it things that you would
normally do as a kid you're doing it as
an as an adult so you're you're aware of
the fact that it's not smooth you don't
get it it doesn't make sense it's not
easy it's not natural it's jagged
words come out wrong [ __ ] that didn't go
right this is what i mean because you're
learning because you're learning and
part of my learning i had to make amends
for because my coping mechanisms were
very interesting but i know that i
needed were they
one was i was a self-righteous little
[ __ ] um so
i started doing this work first i'm
doing this
this you know i'm going all after this
career for myself for me me me
and then i get there it wasn't enough so
then i i started educating myself on
doing something for the world but now
i'm like other people should be using
their platforms for the world like mitch
you started this like three minutes ago
like calm down um so i had i had a
moment of that
um and it was born out of me feeling
like a fraud dealing with impostor
syndrome
trying to cope with that but being an
incredibly defensive little human
and and other aspects of of myself were
that i could be extremely rigid i had
standards of perfection that were
impossible for me to reach let alone
anybody else in my world and i would
extend that you know anybody who was
close to me was an extension of me
oh yeah
so no no boundaries you know oh i hear
you you know have you ever heard of teal
swan yes
i love teal and i learned this from her
it's just simple but what we judge in
others is what we deny in ourselves
no
judgment for all of those things that
people weren't doing that weren't good
enough or weren't perfect like because
you do it to yourself
absolutely absolutely so it was a lot of
that again still haven't had enough time
for cyclic seasons of life to
make themselves present in my awareness
and
when i was 25 i had this moment happen
with someone that i really really loved
and
it was just it smacked me in the face
and i
it was the first time i ever realized
that i was the common denominator in a
lot of my problems
nothing like a little heartbreak to get
you there you know get right in there
i hear you girl
lord almighty i was like every here was
a thing though it was i had done some
[ __ ] up [ __ ] like i've been a cheater
i've been a liar i was a pathological
liar in order to cope i had so many
survival skills man i'm like now i feel
like i would i'm
a total like i'm so rusty on all my
skills cause like before i had to be so
vigilant and i was i could lie at the
drop of a hat like i don't even i
literally freeze if i have to make up
something i'm like oh sorry i was gonna
lie to you but i can't i'm just like you
know
i was gonna respond to you but i just
decided not to because i actually
enjoyed sitting in silence um so i know
that sounds like you're not important
but it's just that i'm a little bit more
important to myself right now
and people are like i don't know what to
do with this level of honesty like i
honestly don't know what to tell you
except that i all i know how to do is be
honest now um
but i was a pathologist
it's so much more effective it's so much
easier you don't have to remember
anything when you're honest you don't
have to remember anything if you're
honest that's what my my mom would
always say my grandmother said if you
tell the truth you won't have to
remember what you said and like i never
really resonated at the time but i'm
like thanks mom now i get it but so so
for me
this moment was really really massive it
was it was the moment that i turned
inward and as you said at the beginning
of our conversation
we go out there looking for the answers
everywhere in the external world and the
journey is inside the journey and the
journey is infinite once you turn inward
and yeah
i i was struck by something that
everyone was saying they kept saying
that um
they kept saying you did nothing wrong
in the situation like i'm so sorry this
happened you did nothing wrong you did
not deserve this and like normally
that's what you want your friends to say
right but i'm like that's not how my
friendships vibe i'm like listen we need
to call each other out on all of our
issues at all costs at all times and
they're like um i just need support
right now i'm like no here's what you
aren't seeing like my friends are like
oh god annalynne
i hear you it's just you can't you know
we're all wired different and we all
have you know we all have different
kinds of friends some match us really
well some are the opposite and you know
it takes all kinds of kinds it takes all
kinds of kinds and it's like for me iron
sharpens iron is the relationships that
i trust
so if you're coming at me and you're
saying hey i love you but [ __ ] what
are you doing like
that is you
you could easily
just be a yes man and this relationship
would just keep floating on but you care
enough to risk
me
that you would stand up and tell me the
truth that means
you're doubling down on this
relationship that means you're doubling
down on me and that means the world to
me that's how i see it so it's a little
it's a little reverse mechanics but
it's it's it's how you know in in again
trauma kids trust is a
it's a luxury we are not afforded so i
had to really find that and and that was
as a result of the emerald journey so
the amber journey started when i was 25
when everyone was saying that i
i didn't do anything wrong i was like
this can't be and all of a sudden i was
like oh wow
i've cheated on partners i've done this
i've done that
it's just this was the one that mattered
this was the one that mattered the most
to me and i was in it to win it and i
got blindsided and i got to feel what it
felt like to be on the other side of
this and that is exactly the type of
friendships that i asked for call me out
the universe was like i'm calling you
out and i got called out and it was
painful it was excruciating i didn't
have all these experiences to be able to
know that cycles you know return and so
the journey inward i started i just
consumed books like four agreements
power of now everything written by
eckhart tolle everything written by don
miguel ruiz everything written by joe
dispenza you know like i just went
to my bookshelf over there going oh yeah
just like i'm sure i'll start listing
all the titles um
but just consuming this information and
then i was in a regurgitation of the
information phase which was you know
super annoying for people i was like
little misinsufferable know it all is
here to let everyone know the isotopic
wisdom that we're all lacking
still
still a little on the self-righteous
path then absolutely on the
self-righteous path holier than thou as
[ __ ] um but my friends are very long
suffering
very very grateful for all of you guys
all three of you um
small number quality versus quantity but
um yeah for sure but
then at at a point when i thought i had
finally
started to make sense of my life
i had gotten to a place where i i was
putting up boundaries i was implementing
them i had realized i had overextended
myself years out and i made a vow to
myself that this one particular
commitment would be the final one and it
was the furthest out and as i completed
all of my commitments because i'm the
type of person who would like show up
dragging my dead ass self jet lagged
tired sick whatever i made a commitment
so i'm gonna stick with it and i was
like everyone was like it's so wonderful
you stick to your commitment something
isn't it
and then i want to collapse you know
your inner child's going we're dying
dude we're dying my inner child's like i
hate you
um
so so june of 2018 i finished that final
commitment outside of myself
two months later
two months almost to the day
following that event
i was in treatment for ptsd
and i had latent memories of childhood
sexual abuse return
and
it was
earth shattering i had lived for 31
years with one story and in a 90 minute
i say this all the time in a 90-minute
session my entire life story changed and
i was she was at a therapy session 90
minute session you mean therapy
session of emdr so my doctor
yeah she she's a specialist in eye
movement desensitization and
reprocessing for post-traumatic stress
disorder
specifically she works with women and
girls who are victims of survivors of
domestic and sexual abuse and and had
you been working with someone
for a long time like since you were 25
and now you're 31 had you did you start
working with a therapist then and so it
was sort of like a build up and how long
had you been doing emdr
so i actually
never went to see a therapist i saw a
therapist like twice i was extremely
resistant probably because my brain
prior to your session 2018 prior to 2018
i had no interest in therapy and i
believe it was my brain i believe that
my brain knew if i was in a treatment
session where someone could see me and
actually see me they would figure it out
and i wasn't ready to know
and i think that that's something that
and just before i answer your question
about emdr and i will go into that i
really want to stress the point
that
your body your brain your cells are
geared to protect you at all costs yeah
they are so kind
they are so kind
the ego
this the the the just the just the
actual biological makeup of the human
is is designed to protect it doesn't
know that the coping mechanism it used
to protect you might be the very thing
that's now harming you but even still we
have to honor that biological process
my body and my brain knew
that if i went into treatment before i
was ready
i would not have the bandwidth i worked
90 hours a week i got on red eyes every
weekend i did i i'm a million miler i
just hit million miles status earlier
this year because i run from my problems
i would get on a plane to anywhere or
nowhere it didn't matter if something
was going on i wanted to get the [ __ ]
out of dodge that was it that was the
whole just running running running i had
to slow down and i had to create safety
for myself and in order to do that
i needed 31 years worth of life to learn
the cycles of life to get to a place
where it was going to be okay enough for
me to then go into eye movement
desensitization reprocessing to go into
emdr
and to answer your question the
i had two intake sessions danica this
was my first emdr session
i had been in therapy all of five
appointments in my whole life
oh my god it was brimming it was it was
brimming it was ready to go
we we did two intake sessions i did a
kundalini breath work workshop on the
sunday following my thursday appointment
and the memory that we were actually
going to tackle was an entirely
different memory
that and this is something i stress a
lot breath work is something i use every
single day and i see you nodding your
head so you you know the power of
pranayama holotropic breath work
i went into a two and a half hour
workshop for
kundalini breathwork it's not like crazy
kundalini everybody like gets all
weirded out if they don't know what it
is um it was just powerful movement of
energy with the breath
and processed this memory and i got into
my next session which was going to be
the first
treatment session where we
use these little buzzers and they
alternate hand-to-hand so it's bilateral
temporal lobe activation allowing the
ceo brain to have control of the mind
and to really revisit things that
weren't safe these in these um explicit
memories excuse me explicit memories are
the ones we log implicit memories are
the ptsd memories that i describe as
memories that float around an empty
space like a feather and then someone
turns on a vacuum when a trigger point
happens and just gets sucked up and you
don't know where you are and what's
happening and it's so immediate right
so
so i had this
this workshop i did
two and a half hours of breath work i
really went through this memory just
came because it was so there we had just
spent the last session talking about at
my doctor and i so i go into the session
the following thursday with my doctor to
actually begin the buzzer process where
we are gonna drop in and look at these
memories and i told my doctor i said i
don't
i don't feel that icky gross feeling
around that memory that we were gonna
look at and
she said well you know she i explained
to her the workshop and she said you
processed she said the process of emdr
the whole point is to
connect the body and the mind i was
completely numb from the neck down
i i would go around like laughing like
oh i have a high tolerance for pain and
i literally i say you don't win awards
for having a high tolerance to pain pain
is a thing we have to have or we i put
my hand over my candle right and i don't
feel heat i burn my hand
right
pain is a beautiful gift exactly
my doctor said that my skin sensitivity
was so low she'd never seen anything
like this in her practice before
my it was so low i literally kept
telling her to turn up the intensities
of the buzzers that i had in my hands
for the process to go she's like i can't
turn it up any higher i couldn't feel
danica my skin like my my ability to
feel was so numb i was so cut off from
body from head to body oh is this why
cutting happens and why you know
physical abuse happens because you're
just doing anything to feel anything
anything to feel anything so you know
the bdsm i didn't like normal sex would
never i wouldn't even know what was
happening i was so
desensitized
and
and
i would cut to feel because i felt so
numb it this my poor little inner child
was was in a house that was terrifying
for 31 years because i left the abusive
situations and started abusing abusing
my own house that she lived in and she
was terrified she was terrified and the
emdr process would introduce me to her
and she didn't want anything to do with
me because
i was she would i would see her in my
mind and she would run into blackness
and disappear and i would tell my doctor
like oh my god what do i do like she
won't stay with me she's like you have
to build trust yeah she doesn't trust
you you've made it very unsafe for her
and i was like i'll do anything yeah
that's true i agree i mean like
i
you know for me when i
met my inner child like at first she was
i describe it like she was in a dome
like at the top of a tower and it was
like a concrete dome and there was like
a little window but she was voiceless
like she had no voice she didn't say
anything and then like as i process more
it's like she came down to the bottom
and then she's kind of standing at the
doorway
and she still didn't talk but at least
she was kind of like a little taller
seemed like she stood up and you know
you know kind of curious about going out
but she wasn't sure if it was safe and
like now we hang out and i'm like hey
how you doing you know anything i should
work on and she literally just goes play
play play
i never played i like didn't play and so
i totally get it like the inner child
does not it's
you have to teach it
by teaching yourself yes
yes you do and one of the one of the
hallmarks of breath work
deep mindfulness meditation and emdr
which i'm so grateful to have been able
to use all of those modalities but if
you can't for whatever reason find an
emdr specialist or you can't afford it
or insurance doesn't cover it breathwork
is free
and it it my doctor said you didn't need
the emdr for that memory because the
breath work was enough it was sufficient
that's my doctor saying that we moved on
to the next memory because she
determined that i had already done what
we were going to do in the room so
that's the power of breath work and and
we we do put a lot of faith in our
doctors but every once in a while we get
an amazing doctor like my doctor
dr charlene ruan and she she by all
means necessary healing she doesn't care
she doesn't have an ego about it she
just wanted me to heal and she knew that
this was going to be something that i
should do alongside of emdr and i
continued and do this day i still do
breath work i don't do emdr anymore but
i still do breath work have you ever
done any have you ever tried any other
modalities that include like as an
example i have a body worker um
here that i use she's amazing and super
spiritual super super into it like she's
lived in peru and done deities and she's
like very all there
um and you're definitely gonna hang out
i just want you to know i am like that's
official
i can't wait
i i actually really believe that will
happen um sooner than later but um
and so i remember i had seen her for a
couple of years and she does amazing
body work she actually uses her feet to
walk on you and to the massage so she
does massage but it's body work and
there's you know emotional and um
energetic things happening
and it was last year and it was kind of
just just before sort of my
is just at the sort of beginning of my
big trauma that happened last year and
uh she's like you know i can you know i
can kind of feel you in a different
place and she's like you know if
anything comes through she's like just
keep going i keep going just kind of
keep going breathe through it whatever
comes through just just just just allow
it and so as she's doing some work and
she's on my back and she's on the spot
and she's like eventually it's like the
spot that won't go away and she goes if
this spot
had a sound what would it be
and so like the first one i gave it like
a little like it's so weird right i mean
all of it can be weird and uncomfortable
until this week i would say yes that's
weird but i've literally been a part of
a virtual sound healing summit and i'm
learning so much about the power of
sound and us
make using our voice to make those
sounds for release so i'm right here
with you
yeah so she said give it a sound and i
was kind of like ah you know like gave
it a sound
it wasn't a real one and then a couple
like 10 seconds went by and all of a
sudden like i made the sound that all of
a sudden just came out and it was like
much louder and bigger and then i just
started bawling wow
and so you're so right that like the the
sound and the audible like the somatic
element of things whether it's breathing
or some sort of verbal you know i mean
have you ever heard of taran toomey she
has the thing called
workout called the class
um she
it's she has an app and she also has a
studio in new york but part of it
includes a lot of
verbal like so it's like you'll call
play a song and then in the song you do
the same movement over and over again
and in it there's encouragement to
make noise so you're like
you know you like really get it out and
what's crazy is that by the end of even
in the middle but definitely by the end
of it when it goes into like the heart
opening which is this just literally you
move your arms back and forth all of a
sudden and verbal prompts help like
questions and things like that but i
mean like most of the time that i do it
it's like all there are tears for
something you know you're processing
something so
uh that's so cool that um you know
you've found techniques and and honestly
so young
well i mean you said it to you said it
about your your little i said your
daughter your your inner child i think
of my inner child as my daughter now but
being being silent being silent for so
long right
of course we need sound of course we
need to find my i gotta you know when
they do those energy readings like the
auric field and your energy centers
my throat center my throat chakra was
black
oh wow yeah
oh wow it's a great response i was more
like oh wow
i was like i i've been doing this work
for a year i'm like wait i've been
working on myself for a long time what
do you mean my throat's still
what i literally i i literally was
blown away by how many parts of my life
i started to realize because when that
stuff like that happens i ask myself
where am i being silenced where am i not
speaking my truth what i realized was i
wasn't being silenced anymore i was
speaking my truth very loudly
i did not know i was allowed to speak my
needs
[Music]
my needs
was a thing that i did not do especially
with men
i did not voice my needs and because of
that my throat was so blocked and sound
has been so profoundly healing and to
your point we're right on this parallel
wavelength but i was in this wild
amazing breath work that was facilitated
by e car wood who is a part owner of
modern nirvana which actually they're
having an amazing thing in austin texas
this weekend a convention with deepak
chopra and all those guys it's all all
of these modalities but he's a
breathwork facilitator and he did a two
and a half hour session with me and i
swear to god i saw the black bubble
thing in my throat
i literally i felt he he even got a
trash can i was like i'm so sorry like i
was like retching it was so intense
sorry guys if you're like really being
grossed out listening to this but it was
so powerful and so beautiful because
here's what's so crazy he turned on a
song and i knew the song after like two
hours of the session and that had
happened and i was coming down from it
and i started singing
i could i could sing like i i don't sing
i sing in the shower i sing in my car my
convertible top down with the wind
blowing he was like you're such a
beautiful singer you know do you do that
with your work and everything and i was
like no no ecar i
i i don't i've never i don't sing i
don't know what that was that was crazy
but my something released in my throat
and
i like
now when i do sound modalities and stuff
i can move all the way up and down the
scales and i would always get these like
little blocks
so all of it everything the body keeps
the score it's actually a book by bessel
vance yeah i bought that book just a few
weeks ago
oh my god read it yet but i i got it
amazing amazing amazing book
life-changing for me and for anyone who
might have felt like it was your fault
that you froze during a sexual assault
or any kind of
any kind of abuses i i remember when i
was sexually assaulted when i was a
teenager out here in la my whole body
just froze and my system shut down and i
was reading the body keeps the score
i'll never forget i burst into tears
because it started talking about how the
system does a system override and sends
you into freeze we always hear about
fight or flight we don't hear about
freezing faint freeze and faint oh [ __ ]
fun or faint free yeah you like you can
lose consciousness right so you can like
you can you can technically faint um but
it's a it's a psycho um you know not a
psychosomatic but um it's a
psychologically induced fainting yeah
but so my body learned to freeze i
breath work was really hard for me
because i never breathed i didn't my my
lungs were actually
incapable of full capacity because my
ribs were concave due to years of
holding my breath during my trauma these
are all things i learned by bodywork and
i'm so grateful again to my doctor for
not saying that western medicine is the
only answer she wanted to work with all
modalities because she wanted me to heal
did you ever well speaking of western
medicine versus eastern were you on ever
taking anything were there any were you
on any kind of antidepressants or
anything ever
yeah i was diagnosed bipolar so my my
family has bipolar i recently had my
brain scanned by dr daniel amen who
believes that we shouldn't just sit
someone in a 30-minute session with a
psychiatrist and then start trying out
pills on them like they're a lab rat we
he said why do we have you come in for a
heart
ekg if you have a heart issue why do we
have you come in to see you know an
ultrasound when you have a stomach issue
and then we just like you know the brain
it's not that important of an organ we
don't really need that one so much as we
need the other ones we won't look at
that and we'll just throw chemicals your
way and good luck i hope it works out
for you he's like i don't understand
this you need to see what you're
diagnosing before you diagnose it so he
scans brains for mental health patients
and he has an incredible book called the
end of mental illness which is a little
controversial the title but it's pretty
brilliant where he goes with all of it
that's amazing and you know for people
listening because i think there are a
lot of people taking something and i
don't want anyone to feel like a loser
or like you're doing it wrong
i think you know i work with this lady
her name's elisa romeo she wrote a book
called meet your soul which is how i met
my soul and gave it a name she's lucy hi
lucy
yeah um but she she talked about
these kinds of medications in a way that
made a lot of sense to me um because i
guess i would come from the other side
of like don't take it like deal with
your [ __ ] you know
suck it up or you know all those kinds
of things probably things that i
shouldn't be saying to myself anymore
but but but i was like hmm
let's listen to this and she she said
that sometimes you're so depressed or
you're so sad and you're so in it so
much anxiety that you literally can't
choose a good thought
so for those holes that you're in where
you just can't get out and you can't
choose a good thought you have to it's
good to take something so you can start
to choose a good different thought so
you can start to
reprogram it's almost like a
neuroplasticity phase where you're like
all like really it's 100 patterning
yourself in a different way and the idea
is to get off of them but in the
beginning if you can't get out of the
hole
and choose a good thought that they can
be really helpful to re-patterning and
to getting on the right track
absolutely i know some people so many
people no but i experienced both sides
because i was put on lumiktol i was put
on a mood stabilizer after being
diagnosed with bipolar because i was in
a depression that i could not get out of
and for that exact purpose and because
you're
all into the brain
when we do something repetitively the
brain learns it the brain learns
depression the brain learns anxiety it
repeats it because it's experiencing it
over time
so to unlearn it we do need assistance
and if modalities like breath work and
and meditation and all of these things
aren't make aren't cutting it or you're
not at that place where you're
interested in it yet whatever the case
may be
because of the symptoms that i had that
were in alignment with bipolar they were
trauma induced because they've been
healed once i got through my trauma so i
couldn't really have bipolar if i no
longer have bipolar symptoms bipolar is
seen as a chemical imbalance which means
it is incurable unlike a personality
disorder or something that is alterable
it is so to be diagnosed as bipolar and
then to no longer show symptoms of
bipolar with no medication consistently
for two and a half years which is where
i'm at now
there's there was a little something
going on with my psychiatrist diagnosis
of me right well it's opening you know
you were a child and you know probably i
mean the the brain is the final frontier
we don't get it that's why there's a
million i interviewed neil degrasse
tyson and he's like whenever there's
someone writing a lot of books about
something it's because they don't get it
they don't know there's a lot of books
about consciousness in the mind and how
everything works but um but you know so
it's imaginable that you know as we
continue to discover that you know
there's
you know disassociative personality
disorder which is what you then were
which you which is what more actually
what you had versus bipolar right yes
right so split as a kid because you had
to be you couldn't be yourself so you
had to go be this other person and you
had to you just had to re-emerge that
remarkably i had to exactly i had to
integrate and and it's so you know i
think the i think the most important
thing for anyone who might be
experiencing this right now or or being
uncertain that you're experiencing it
because i didn't know i was splitting i
i i had the sense that i had bipolar
because i ticked all the boxes i had
hyper sexuality
hyper spending or hyper frugality i
would go i would swing between
impulsively spending to impulsively to
being really really like i'm not going
to park in a meter and drive around the
block 10 times to find it like i
literally i can afford a two dollar
meter i don't know why i'm tripping um i
had
like in you know um insomnia um
grandiosity um i don't know if the
grandiosity went away completely um
that one's that one's still my ego
working on that um but i ticked like
seven out of nine boxes and was
diagnosed with mild hippomania
and what bessel vanderkolt talks about
in that book that you just got the body
keeps the score is how he's fought for
at that point over 25 years with the
american psychiatrist association
to have them put in the diagnostic
statistics manual the manual that all
psychiatrists have to purchase
every couple five years or whatever it
is when they update it to put into that
book that trauma is something that
people have and that it should be looked
at when you're treating people and
giving them chemicals and putting them
in their bodies so i'm on both sides of
it i'm both grateful for the mood
stabilizer that absolutely i'm so
grateful i was on it when my memories
came back
because i did not go into
what could have been a really horrific
downward spiral due to the instability
of the patterns of my brain at that time
but then i retrained my brain through
all of the healing modalities i began
and by
november of 2000 and
was it 2019
yeah by november of 2019 so my memories
came back in august of 2018. by november
of 2019
i went off my medication with my doctor
i told i didn't go back to my
psychiatrist because he was already
trying to like have me go on something
else the more i told him i was doing
well he was like sure that it was my
grandiosity i was trying to put me on
different things i talked to my doctor
who's an actual phd and has a background
in neuroscience and knows the brain very
well so specializing in emdr which is
specifically a treatment of the brain
right
and she said let's watch how you do
and if
in
and then we went into 2020. i should
have had a lot of episodes going on in
2020 right i had
i i'm
exactly who's talking to you right now
as who i've been over the last year and
a half
all through this situation and that was
coming off of the medication finding
modalities that help me that are free
and coinciding them with treatment that
thankfully i was able to you know have
insurance pay for
but now you know my maintenance is
every day i do that work and i i there's
a little thing that i um and i know
we've we talked i just realized the time
i'm like god i could talk to you forever
um my um
my inner child when i met her and she
was running from me and all the things
and i had to learn to trust her one of
the things that began to build the trust
was i went back into all the memories
that i had the memories that weren't
fragmented the ones that i actually had
that were not so wonderful and i had
plenty of not so wonderful memories on
that i did remember prior to august
2018.
i went back into those memories in my
mind so i closed my eyes and i imagined
myself and then i was like you know what
i'm going to have a few more anilins i
decided to bring an army of anilines 32
anilins geared up and we stormed into
those memories and i got my little self
out of those memories i picked her up
told anyone who was hurting her you want
to [ __ ] come at us because we'll rip
your face off and
and i came out with this mama bear
protective love energy and that was how
it began and i started to gain her trust
and then i would do magic tricks because
kids love magic i was i was like i don't
give a [ __ ] i will do anything to get my
child to trust me i was intent on my
inner child trusting me and not running
from me anymore in my mind and i didn't
care how i got there so i created this
army inside my mind and i would go in
and i would imagine the the bad memory i
would walk up the street i would i would
literally like see myself in my army of
aniline strutting down the street turn
down the driveway fling open the door
i'm like hey [ __ ]
we're about to throw down right now and
i was like i and it was amazing because
my mind would play with me and and i i
had one moment where
my little self i had gotten good at this
so now i was like oh now i know what to
do just come in like you know
beat some face get my little self out
we're good you know and then i had one
memory where i couldn't get little me
out
and that's when i realized that my mind
was actually
playing back with me but i was not in
control of it
and this was a little this was both
enlightening and terrifying so what i
did was exactly what i'd done with all
these other memories and i always was
able to pick her up and we leave the
memory and and then i in my mind i felt
like that i had
taken that moment and healed it because
i got her out and i made her safe i
became the woman that my little me
needed and i showed up for her and in
time and space in my brain
i was able to make those moments happen
and heal those spots well then i had
this memory and i go to pick up my
little self just like normal and i'm
like okay out of here let's fly girl and
she drops like lead to the ground
and i and i see the person who's coming
to sexually abuse her and it's not the
one who is normally perpetrating onto
her someone else
and i'm i'm seeing him getting closer
and i'm like no like i'm i'm gonna i'm
gonna kick this guy's at like no you
have like we gotta get out of here like
i started getting frantic in my own mind
at a situation that was just in my own
mind but i but it felt so real and i
didn't know why i couldn't get her out
and i all of a sudden i said i need to
trust my mind our bodies want to heal
themselves right i always use the
example of you got to cut on your arm
you don't have to be like coagulate
blood scab over
new skin growth you know the body's like
um lady i got this the mind is the same
way just create a safe clean environment
a safe clean space for the wound to heal
same in the mind when i opened up and
said please help me get her out of here
i was able to find a way to
to
utilize the the people in my spouse i
started bringing in other people other
sources i brought in a child version
of one of the perpetrators who i loved
who was someone in the community
and
before he was abused i i my mind went
back and got him
at eight years old i don't know i
wouldn't know to think to do this my
mind did this by itself and it was
literally like i was watching a movie
now in my own mind and it's like shit's
going down and i'm like i'm not in
control
but this this little boy version of this
person who grows up to be someone that i
love to then when i'm 31 remember that
he harmed me
i'm so like he's now he opens the door
to the shed that that was in the part of
the memory was where i was being held
and
he runs in and he dives onto the ground
and picks up my little self
my cat's making an important a little
appearance
he he opens the door to the shed he
dives in
and runs he starts crying
dives to the ground and picks up little
me we're about the same age about the
same size at that point he's like
somebody help her somebody please help
her she needs help she's hurting
i was i literally came out of the emdr
session with my doctor and i started
balling my eyes out and i was like
i started learning compassion i started
learning all of these tools all of these
techniques we talked about alchemy at
the beginning of the conversation this
was how i learned to alchemize
my trauma because because that was the
same boy who would grow up and harm me
later but in this memory he was
he was good he was so good and he was
helping me and i got me out such a truth
indicator right like i got goosebumps
when you were saying that because i
could feel like it's an indicator for me
of when truth is being spoken or when
truth is happening and that's the truth
and that isn't that the truth generally
i believe that to be the truth about
about everybody really is that it's
something that happened it's you know
this sort of trigger projection game
that we play
in
friendships partnerships especially
family dynamics it's it's
it's coming from it's like the trigger
is the teacher and the projection is the
indicator like what why am i projecting
what is this telling me about myself
triggers going okay this is the teacher
if i'm being triggered what is this
saying about myself it's always about
it's it's never just about you people
take take things so personally and i was
definitely one of them same
definitely and
it's not usually about you someone's
treatment of you says a lot more about
how they feel about themselves than it
does about you well and they're often
not doing it against you they're doing
it for them and that's the thing that we
don't you know and we and we want to be
seen for how we're not trying to do
something against someone else we're
doing it for ourselves but we oftentimes
have difficulty
don miguel ruiz i go back to the first
book i ever read four agreements
don't make assumptions don't take things
personally be impeccable with your word
always do your best because on a tuesday
your best might be amazing and by
thursday you might be [ __ ] out of luck
so whatever your best is be kind to
yourself i learned kindness to my inner
child i learned compassion i learned
kindness and compassion and if we looked
around at 7.8 billion people in the
world and instead we saw 7.8 billion
inner children in the world
we would be a lot kinder it would be a
lot kinder it's it would be a complete a
completely different world but i you
know the biggest thing i there's one
last thing i'll say about the inner
child thing
that that has been really impactful in
the experience i've been leading inner
child workshops so one of the reasons i
was in arizona was the wellness center
savannah that um
i was visiting in carefree arizona and
yeah
your owners yeah it's so close to you um
so we're gonna do that together for sure
um
but the
the owners of that
wellness center had such beautiful
intentionality behind creating it and
they wanted to create a space that was
affordable but also was a place where
you could go and have an actual wellness
retreat and you could find yourself or
find these healing modalities and learn
things to take back into your world and
we were talking and and they've asked me
to put together curriculum so i might be
collaborating with them and doing
potentially like a like a you know four
times a year kind of situation three-day
weekend workshop but one of the
workshops we were talking about was one
that i do um
as much as i can with the the groups
that i work in and it's
kind of the three days we normally do
the at least the inner child workshop
but the three days is past present
future so past is
me reintroducing yourself or introducing
yourself
for the first time as an adult to your
inner child and and integrating and
reconnecting those dots and beginning
that process
two is present so dancing with your
shadow
we learn to
not be angry and upset and hiding those
rejected parts of ourselves but oh hey i
see why you're a little [ __ ] sometimes
let's dance let's have a little dance
with that [ __ ] self
and and how can i take it from here in
an alchemical way how can i transmute
this energy that you want to give that's
really powerful and probably protective
and important but maybe i can execute in
a different way so we learned to dance
with our shadow in the present moment
and then future self we go into the
future in our minds and we design that
self that we
that we take from that very first day
of the dreams of the inner child why did
i dream to be an actress and an
archaeologist and a math tutor which was
also one of my dreams
i now am like literally like work in all
those worlds i'm i'm i all of the
ancient modalities of ancient egypt are
a big part of my world which uses the
language of math
and i'm an actress and literally the
things that my little self was
interested in have become things that
are an intrinsic part of my healing life
journey right now and and will continue
to be so we we take those important
wisdom moments from our child self and
apply them to where we are or might not
be in our lives and can we revisit that
in looking at the future self and so
it's the whole idea is is
we make such an emphasis on getting a
relationship a partner friends whatever
and we don't build a relationship with
the person we spend the most time with
we don't build a relationship with
ourselves we don't wake up in the
morning if you had a six-year-old little
girl hanging out in your house you would
probably say good morning to her you'd
probably ask her how she slept and get
her some oatmeal or cereal or something
right we don't check in with our inner
child i'm the same as you you said
earlier like i'm now i'm like hey boo
what's up and i know if she wants candy
we're good like she's cotton candy for
some reason it's not a healthy diet but
it's what she loves so and i know that
she's happy if she has cotton candy when
i see her if she doesn't have cotton
candy mama bear's got a throw down so
it's like i'm glad little anna's got
cotton candies
those those have been and the first
thing we do with the inner child
workshops is i ask everyone to close
their eyes
and to get a beautiful image of that
little self just just really see that
little self in the mind's eye
and and
bring that child in and maybe you pick
him or her up and you put that child in
your lap and you put your hands on their
face and you look in their eyes and you
say
i am so sorry for all of your pain
i'm so sorry for all of the times you
felt
unseen and unheard
i'm so sorry you're doing what i did so
many times
i would literally like hug myself like
this and just tell myself like tell my
inner child i've got you yes and the
dialogue was always i've got you i i and
then it's like the inner child's like
i've got you two i always have like
higher selfs like i've got you i always
have
inner child is learning i'm saying i've
got you you know and it's just you just
gotta have them and they'll have you and
a hundred percent a beautiful
relationship it's a beautiful
relationship and one of the things that
i immediately did once i realized oh i'm
maybe i need her to have me more than
i've got or her i was like please be my
guide i have no attachment to my body i
was learning to feel again through all
the numbness and i said i don't know
when i feel bad will you tell me will
you tell me when something doesn't feel
right because i don't trust my own self
because i've been so cut off between my
body and my mind like my head to my body
were just chopped like there was the
feeling was so low and i didn't get
those gut instinct feelings that people
feel i didn't have those i don't know
wow has that come back because
oh yeah i'm like ow like you pinched me
like i feel everything now but i also
feel the intuition and gut but i would
go like my friends would always put me
in the front at like one of those like
haunted like you know not scary farm or
whatever things yeah look nothing scared
me you could jump out at me
my sense my my sensitivity to things was
so not there i just i was like oh i'm
supposed to be scared by you but i'm not
like it was just delayed it was it was
it was crazy have you read all of that's
back now thank you your love and empathy
and care for other people went up too as
you started
doing it for yourself because i was kind
of one of those people that stayed a
little disassociative to kind of things
and just push through
and so i tended to kind of inflict that
same idea onto people like just push
through and now i i just sometimes it's
right away but other times something
will happen somebody will share
something and i'll and i'll start and
i'm like wait no thank you for sharing
that that was beautiful that was really
that had to it might be easy now but
there was a point in time that was very
hard and you know there's there you know
to honor the person as it goes like that
wasn't something that even registered as
much with me before i healed those
things and so it was like i'd say this a
lot but as i break open to more pain it
accesses more pleasure yes which is
actually
it's actually one of the hermetic
principles right the
the
the polarity of things
you gotta go get it did you know that i
read the kabillion i read the the
it's literally it was the last book i
just finished the seven medic principles
yeah i i and i also went to egypt
earlier this year i love egypt holy [ __ ]
i've always been so interested in egypt
but i just read this from the the seven
hermetic principles and and that was one
of the last few about that it does
actually take the pain to access the
pleasure for some reason there's
that's the way it works yes and then the
master initiates learn to balance that
pendulum swing so they that once once
you felt that pain and then you begin to
alter the vibration you're able to
transmute and that that is what i loved
about the kabbalian because i i've
literally i
i was listening to it yesterday i've
literally listened to it like five times
on audible because
you i get something new every single
time since there's a lot of information
and it's it's a lot like that
yeah i mean i fell asleep many times
reading it just because it's like so
much to take in
it's a lot to take in um but yeah that
that for me
was
realizing that that the pendulum had
swung and would swing backwards and and
yes to answer your question i absolutely
noticed my empathy and and understanding
for other people
for me it changed i had a sense of it
because i know boundaries i was like i
could feel everybody's feelings but but
then i would be i would be a little
stilted with certain things that like
you said i could just push through
because i was disassociative or i was
numb and i didn't understand why people
couldn't just
get it together handle it you know yeah
and and now as you said too i i honor
that in myself so i can honor that in
someone else but also just like we don't
hear
you did a good job
you did so good well we always hear when
we get it wrong i mean that's the
biggest thing for my inner child was
just going in like you did so good
you did so good you you learned to be a
bully you learned to be abusive to
partners those things but you did so
good because those were the tools you
had and i have new tools now that we can
introduce and we don't have to do those
things anymore and we can make amends
but you did everything right with what
you had that was all you had to do it
with and you did so good and and i bring
that into myself a lot and i've been
able to
extend that now out from me to other
people and a lot of people respond that
wow
i don't remember the last time i heard
that i did good
and it's crazy how simple it is
it's crazy how simple it is just
something like that that goes brings us
all the way back
again our inner children leading the way
with their wisdom
simplicity and wisdom play
eat cotton candy
people and fun we should listen
well what a brave journey thank you i i
mean again it's like
there's going to be people that hear
this that are going to go oh you know
they're going to hear maybe something
for the first time that they've never
heard before but i always say that it's
you know never underestimate ever trying
to make anyone say think or do something
but it's seeds right like there might be
something that happens somewhere later
on and they'll be like hmm
and usually the second time you hear it
or think about it it's really a
changing moment as opposed to the first
so sometimes this might be some of the
first time people heard this stuff maybe
it's the second time in the moment that
they really need to um they're really
realize that they're going to do
something about what's going on but
man life is such an interesting
experience it's like the it's all
feedback about you right it's just the
craziest thing i i've asked many people
like i i've asked a few really smart
people one of them you'd probably love
naseem haramine have you ever love him
oh my gosh
yeah i was like i can't wait to go
through your archives i'm actually new
to podcast i i always listen to books so
i was like i'm learning all the new
podcasts and yours is definitely i'm
gonna go back all the way to the
beginning because i am so just just the
way that you bring so much of your truth
and and your narrative into
the dialogue and and really deepen the
points i really appreciate as an
interviewee but i'm sure as a listener
that's amazing so i'm i'm excited to
just veg out on you
forgive me if i start fangirling next
time i see you
it'll be the same it'll be the same i
just need you to do one thing though
when i see you it's like panthers out
okay
i was gonna do it right now but i'm like
you know what i'm gonna wait i'm gonna
do that for you in person we're gonna
we're gonna have a whole moment i love
it i love it well thank you and you know
i i'm i'm gonna
say that i'm sure that your inner child
is
is so glad that you see her now and
that life kept showing you scenarios
obviously that was about being seen and
what you wanted to get from someone else
was exactly what you were supposed to
give to yourself
and you gave that to yourself and your
life is completely different and i know
that people that get on the healing
journey it's not [ __ ] pretty it's
really actually quite emotionally ugly
at times
it's it's a it's a ride that you never
get off because it's really just like
new levels of reality for you of joy and
and perspective and patience and
compassion and
it it does make you a whole new you but
a better you i i think there's always a
fear around it's like joe's book
breaking the habit of being yourself i
feel like people
hear that a lot and maybe it's my own
mind saying this but they you know you
read that and you think well i like me
and i don't want to change who i am and
it's like not about that you can't
change your essence the reason why
you're here today and why you were there
10 years ago and why you made it from
trailer park to the big screen is
because your essence is that
vibrant and that
magnetic and that powerful that no
matter what [ __ ] was going on down below
your essence is always there your inner
child your higher self whatever you want
to call it and so the the transition of
like getting
being a whole different person is really
about how is about is really more your
perception
your perception in life changes and then
you feel like a whole different person
but
your essence has always been there since
you were a little kid that's why you had
like your big boy pants and you've got
[ __ ] done and why you have an army of 32
yeah and why you're doing what you're
doing now and why you're brave enough to
say the things that you're saying so
thank you so much
absolutely and i'll just add one last
thing to that because i think what you
what you said really resonates
with something that i found in my life i
would make
i learned to make the exact same
decisions with the exact same outcome no
longer from fear but from love instead
of being afraid for my well-being i love
myself enough to take care of my
well-being and make that same decision
and and and remove myself from a dynamic
or whatever it was but i was doing it
from a different place and so
the power of perception has been the
most profound aspect of my whole
existence as it is for all of us so i
appreciate that and i appreciate you and
this has been so wonderful thank you for
having me thank you well we'll see you
um you're going to be here next weekend
right you're coming to hang out yeah
yeah obviously
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button